Uh, let me just share my saving rewards,
right?
Yeah, the screen redesign.
And.
Yes.
OK.
You can see my screen.
Yeah.
OK, cool. So uh, what you've got on there?
Um.
What you're seeing here is the.
Is a few screens actually,
or two screens at least? Yep.
Yeah.
So the left section,
which is this component.
So if you see this, this is uh.
Yeah.
This is the the red card basically.
So this component is what is called a
card or a toil and it appears on the list
of.
Go to dashboard, start saving,
start saving.
Yeah.
So show me.
So yeah,
this this card is this is redesigned to
be this. Yep, then we have.
Yeah.
This second screen which is a detailed
screen.
So when you click on find out more you'll
see the second screen which is the
current version looks like this.
But we want it to be different.
There are two views of the screen.
On the left is a mobile view and on the
right hand side you have the a full
desktop view.
Yeah,
so the changes need to be applied to.
Um.
The changes need to be applied to both
the screens,
the list of tiles or list of cards screen,
the card listing screen, let's call it,
Yeah, and the details, OK.
and the card detail screen.
Yeah.
However,
I think we can break it into two power
pieces of work because they are two
different screens,
they're going to remain two different
screens,
and the visual components are very
different.
I don't know your thoughts on that.
Yeah, that sounds good.
OK. Then in terms of information,
it's roughly the same across the two of
these. So what is different is,
for example,
this action often pays itself off within
five years, yeah.
Yeah.
I don't think we have have that
information here,
so for now I think it'll be lorem ipsum.
OK.
Um,
and we can we can see where that where
the content team can provide this to us.
Otherwise we'll hide that section that
part.
OK.
So there's an image at the top.
This the star. The stars remain the same.
Yeah.
So what do the stars mean?
Yes, stars.
So they didn't exist on this screen,
OK.
but that information's available.
So this so it the stars indicate how
OK.
complex is this job. So would you?
Is it a DIY thing? Is it something that?
OK.
Non DIY can do like you know you're
putting a lid on the saucepan that's that
you don't need a DIY to be a DIY expert
to do that.
But if it was cavity wall insulation you
probably want to call an actual
experienced certified.
Insulator to help you with this.
Yeah.
Yeah,
so the examples on on this one give you
that that idea. Professionals only.
So cavity wall, Yep, professionals only.
Oven door seals.
You can replace them if you know how your
way around a screwdriver and beginner as
in change the heating down.
So you anyone can do this.
OK.
Yep.
So the stars.
Stars will come from the complexity level
and it's somewhere in the.
Yeah, I think there's only like one star,
three star or five star.
And that means five star is professionals.
I think it's more.
It's just there is only ever three
different.
Complexity levels and the stars are just
to show that you know it's high
complexity and one is low complexity.
OK,
but where where will the developer be
able to get that information from?
It's significant.
Oh,
this should be there in the data model
somewhere.
I think I can I'll I can link the data
OK.
schema so they can see.
So it's the wrenches.
So this is 5 wrenches.
Yeah, OK.
Uh,
this will be replaced by stars in the
future and that color scheme will also
follow.
You know it's a red because it's high
complexity,
green if it's the lowest complexity.
OK, so yeah,
if they were to click on that link and go
to the next screen,
then they'll they'll they'll be able to
identify like where to pick up that from
from that element which shows the
wrenches.
Yeah,
wherever these wrenches are coming from,
Yeah.
that that's the same information that
will be surfaced here as stars basically.
OK.
Actually I also found the content.
This action often based that little bit
of editorial is also on the detail screen,
so it's in here.
OK.
So we do have the data already,
so it doesn't need to be Lorem Ipsum.
OK.
Yep.
There is this info block on the as is
like current version.
So are we getting rid of that?
There's an info button no on the tile on
More info.
Oh, on the OK, one second info. Oh.
the tile view.
Yes. So this information, I think, uh,
we're saying it should be in there.
There's no reason for this to be shown
separately.
So is it being cated for in the the Figma
for the style?
No, it's not there on this time.
I think we're saying that this
information is not.
I mean that information is available on
the detail screen anyways.
OK, so we don't need to have this problem.
So, uh,
there's no reason for a modal that kind
of pop up thing maybe?
OK.
Should we go through the details screen
as well?
So.
Yeah.
We can maybe assign the card detail
screen to dev to have a look at.
I'm not sure if we have all of this
information,
but we'll we'll see now and find out what
what we can support.
Yeah, sounds good. Yeah.
Yeah. Should we go through detail then?
All right, so detail. I think it's yeah,
it's self-explanatory what it is.
I'll just try and see if I can map it to
the detail screen here. So helps with.
That's the first section.
This action helps with,
so there's a little bit of change to the
labels we're using it seems,
and there's an icon involved now.
Yeah, then saving heating it.
So this list is probably coming from a
Yeah.
data element in the in the database.
Yeah,
it's it's in the current view as well.
Yeah, yeah.
OK, so you you is,
is this the current view? Yeah.
Yeah.
OK, so.
Then we have how to get started and
getting started.
So there's one to one mapping to all of
the elements, right? OK,
Getting started.
Yeah.
and then there's tips and recommendations
and there's bullet points.
So I think this data must be coming.
Tips.
It's possible that we don't have this as
the as bullet points as separate data
points.
The same for getting how to get started
is a paragraph, which is fine,
but it's possible that tips and
recommendations ends up being a paragraph
as well. Depends on how.
Data we see.
So we should just do what what is there
in the data and then we can have a chat
with Steve whether we want to match the
bullet point formatting and in that case
we'll have to change the data itself.
OK.
More resources and more info.
Is that like similar kind of savings
trust?
Uh.
And everything, yeah.
Yeah, looks looks done for you, yeah,
but this looks like a paragraph and.
This then is the list of bullets to show.
Um.
Yeah,
I think we should we should start with a
simple structure here.
OK, like paragraph view.
Yeah, we keep what is.
We keep the same kind of text here and
then.
How do we want to track these things?
So tips and more info we need to find out
from Steve and that's a you and me thing
to find out from Steve whether we can get
this into in a data format that we can
use.
Yeah.
It.
Uh.
Is it?
Is it worth like a first getting what we
have as is and then um probably do
another round for formatting?
Yeah, I think we should, yeah,
we should do the this open piece.
We we do a second pass of the same screen
maybe. Yeah, I agree.
Yeah.
OK. And there's like a view.
Are those like the links to?
Yeah, links. Instead of being a link,
they made it a title.
So it feels like we might have that data.
So if I look at this more info,
Yeah.
how to install cavity wall insulation,
that's one part.
Yeah.
Energy Saving Trust is the second part.
So maybe this is the same thing and the
view is just a link, right?
Yeah, it just opens up a.
Yeah,
so maybe we have all the information
already. We need to find out.
Yeah.
Or the devs can find out if they can find
all the information that they need to
build this view.
And then there's a confirm button which
is similar to what we have before right
now. Would you like to confirm the saving?
Yeah.
So these icons with the green ones with
the are.
Are there either like a finite set of
icons available somewhere?
I don't think so. That's a good question.
You might need to find out how many
different types you can have. So this was.
All energy, household waste.
Let's see if this is different.
So if you see getting started is empty,
I think that this is the full set and
information may be missing in some cases.
The icons,
I mean the sections are the same across
everything, so I imagine icons.
The set of icons we need is finite as
well.
OK.
Is it possible we don't have them at the
moment like that?
Yes,
it's very likely we don't have these
icons,
so we'll have to ask the devs who can if
OK.
they can create these icons.
I think the person who did these designs,
his name is Dorian.
He might have provided Steve a dump of
these icons.
OK, so there's two things from Steve. Um,
so the first one we were thinking about
Um.
like the bullet points which we can,
we said probably we can do that in the
Yeah.
second pass,
but these icons we probably need right
now.
Yes. Yeah. OK. Yeah.
OK.
OK. Yeah, I think, yeah,
that's that should be, that should be it.
Anything else?
Cool.
OK. OK. Thank you, Sandeep.
Yeah, no worries. Yes,
I'll share the transcript of the phone.
Thanks. Cheers. Bye.
Bye.